arguably one of the most important
molecules in all of biology is ATP ATP
which stands for adenosine adenosine tri
tri phosphate tri phosphate which sounds
very fancy but all you need to remember
or anytime you see kind of ATP hanging
around in some type of a biochemical
reaction you should just something in
your brain should say hey we're dealing
with biological energy or another way to
think of ATP is the currency it's the
currency I'll put that in quotes of
biological energy biological energy so
how is it a currency of energy well ATP
stores energy in its bonds and I'll
explain what that means in a second and
before we learn what an adenosine group
or three phosphate groups looks like you
can just take a bit of a leap of faith
that you could imagine
ATP as being made up of something called
and do it a nice color an adenosine
group right there and then it's attached
to it you might have you'll have three
phosphates not might you will you'll
have three phosphates attached to it
just like that and this is ATP ATP
adenosine triphosphate tri meaning three
phosphate groups now if you take
adenosine triphosphate and you hydrolyze
this bond which means if you take this
in the presence of water so let me just
throw some water in here so let's say I
have some h2o then one of these
phosphate groups will break off
essentially part of this water joins to
this phosphate group and then part of it
joins to this phosphate group right
there and I'll show you that in a little
bit more detail but I want to give you
the big picture first what you're left
with is an adenosine group that now has
two phosphates on it so now it has two
phosphates on it and this is called
adenosine diphosphate or a DP before we
had triphosphate which means three
trosset phosphates now we have dye
phosphate
adenosine so instead of a try here we
just try to die which means you have two
phosphate groups and it's been so that
the ATP has been hydrolyzed or you've
broken off one of these phosphate groups
and so now you're left with ADP and then
an extra phosphate group right here and
and this is the whole key to everything
that we're talk about when we're dealing
with ATP and you have some energy and
you have some energy and so when I talk
about ATP being the current of currency
of biological energy this is why is that
if you if you have ATP and if you were
to through some chemical reaction you
pop off this phosphate right here it's
going to generate energy that energy can
be used for just general Heat or you
could couple this reaction with other
reactions that require energy and then
those reactions will be able to move
forward so you know I've been draw these
circles adenosine and phosphates and
really this is all you need to know what
I have you know just already what I've
shown you right here is really all you
need to know to kind of operationally
think of how ATP operates in most
biological systems and if you want to go
the other way if you have energy and you
want to generate ATP the reaction will
just go this way energy plus a phosphate
group plus some ADP you can go back to
ATP and so this is stored energy so this
side of the equation is stored energy
and this side of the equation is used
energy and this is really all you well
this is this is this'll this is 95% of
what you need to know to really
understand the function of ATP in
biological systems it's just a store of
energy when you ATP has energy when you
break a phosphate off it generates
energy and then if you want to go from
ADP and a phosphate back to ATP you have
to use energy up again so if you have
ATP that's a source of energy if you
have ADP and you want ATP you need to
use energy and so far I've you know I've
just drawn a circle with an a around it
and said that's an adenosine but
sometimes I think it's satisfying to see
what the molecule actually looks like so
I cut and pasted this from Wikipedia and
the reason why I didn't show it this to
you initially is because this looks very
complicated while the conceptual reason
why ATP is the currency of energy I
think is fairly straightforward
it has three phosphate one phosphate can
break off and then that will result with
some energy being put into the system or
if you want to attach that phosphate you
have to use up energy that's just the
basic principle of ATP but this is it's
actual this is its actual structure but
even here we can break it down and see
that it's really not too bad
we set adenosine let me draw the
adenosine group we have adenosine this
right here is adenosine this part of the
molecule right there that is adenosine
adenosine and for those of you that have
you know really paid attention to some
of the other videos you might recognize
that this part of adenosine so this is
called adenosine but this part right
here is adenine that right there is
adenine which is the same adenine that
that makes up the nucleotides that's the
backbone of DNA so some of these
molecules in our and biological systems
have more than one use this is the same
adenine where we talk about adenine and
guanine and this is a purine and you
know there's also the piramide ins but I
won't go into that much but that's the
same molecule so that's just an
interesting thing the same thing that
makes up DNA is also part of what makes
up these energy currency molecules so
that's part of the adenine makes part of
the adenosine part of ATP and then the
other part right here is ribose ribose
ribose which you might also recognize
from RNA RNA ribonucleic acid that's
because you have ribose dealin in the
whole situation but I won't go into that
much but ribose is just a five carbon
sugar the when they don't draw the
molecule it's implied that it's a carbon
so this is one carbon right there two
carbons three carbons four carbons five
carbons and that's just nice to know
it's nice to know that they kind of
share parts of their molecules with with
DNA and that these are kind of familiar
building blocks that we see over and
over again but I want to emphasize that
knowing this or memorizing this in no
way will help you understand kind of the
simpler understanding of ATP just being
what drives biological reactions and
then here I drew the three phosphate
groups
and that's that this is their actual
molecular structure their Lewis
structures right here that's one
phosphate group this is a second
phosphate group and this is a third
phosphate group just like that and then
your so you know when I first learned
this my my first question was okay I can
I can take this as a leap of faith that
you know if you take one of these
phosphate groups off or if this bond is
hydrolyzed that somehow that releases
energy and then I kind of went on and
answered all the questions that I had to
answer but why does it release energy
what is it about this bond that releases
energy remember all bonds are our
electrons being shared with different
atoms so the best way you could think
about it is right here did this these
electrons that are being shared right
across this bond or this electron that's
being shared right across this bond and
it's coming from the phosphate I won't
draw the periodic table right now but
you know that phosphate has five
electrons to share it's less
electronegative and oxygen so oxygen
will kind of hog the electron but this
electron is very uncomfortable there's a
couple of reasons why it is
uncomfortable it's it's in a high energy
state one reason is why you have all of
these negative oxygens here so they kind
of want to push away from each other so
these this oxygen these are these
electrons and this bond really can't
kind of get close to the nucleus so go
into kind of a low energy state all of
this is kind of is more of an analogy
than the reality we all know that
electrons can get quite complex and you
know there's a whole quantum mechanical
world but that's a good way to think of
it that these molecules want to be away
from each other but you have these bonds
so this electron is kind of in a high
energy state it's further from the
nucleus is of these two atoms then it
might want to be and when you pop this
phosphate group off all of a sudden
these electrons can enter into a lower
energy state and that generates energy
so now this energy right here is always
in fact in any chemical reaction where
they say energy is generated it's always
from electrons going to a lower energy
state electrons going to lower energy
state that's what it's all about and
later in future videos we do cellular
respiration and glycolysis and all of
that glycolysis when
we show energy it's really from its
electrons going from kind of
uncomfortable States to more comfortable
states and in the process they generate
energy you know if I'm in a plane or I'm
jumping out of a plane you know I have a
lot of potential energy right when I
jump out of the plane and you can kind
of view that as an uncomfortable state
and then when I'm sitting on my couch on
you know watching football I have a lot
less potential energy so that's a very
comfortable state and I could have
generated a lot of energy falling to the
to my couch but I don't know that my my
analogies always break down at some
point the last thing I want to kind of
go over for you is exactly how this
reaction happens you know so far you
could turn off this video and you can
already deal with ATP as is used in 95%
of biology especially ap bio but I want
to let you understand how this reaction
actually happens so to do that what I'm
going to do is copy and paste parts of
these so I already told you that this
guy right here is going to break off he
is going to break off of the ATP so let
me copy and paste him down here edit
paste so that's the phosphate group that
breaks off and then you have the rest of
it you have the ADP that's left over so
this is the ADP I don't even have to
copy and paste all of this stuff you can
just accept but that's the event Essene
group copy and then paste just like that
so we've already said that this thing
gets hydrolyzed off or gets cut off and
it that generates energy and what I want
to do is actually show you the mechanism
a little bit of a hand wavy mechanism of
how this actually happens so I said that
this reaction occurs in the presence of
water so let me draw some water here so
I could have an oxygen and a hydrogen
and then I have another hydrogen that's
water right there
so hydrolysis is just a reaction where
you say hey you know this guy here he's
got a you know he wants to bond with
something or he wants to share someone
else's electrons so maybe this hydrogen
right here goes down here and shares its
electron with this oxygen right here and
then this phosphorus heat well it has it
has an extra electron that it needs to
share remember it has
valence electrons and wants to share
them with oxygen it has one two three
four being shared right now well if this
if this hydrogen goes to this guy then
you're left with these this blue o H
right here and this guy can share one of
this the phosphorus is extra electrons
so you could do H just like that so
that's the actual process that happens
and it could go in the other it could go
the other way as well I could have
cleaved it here
I could have cleaved the whole thing
here and so this guy would have kept the
oxygen and the hydrogen would have gone
to him and then this guy would have
taken the O way it could happen in
either order and and so either order
would be fine
and there's one other kind of point I
want to make and this is a little bit
more complex so I'm I was even wondering
what I want to make it you know my whole
reason why you're kind of in a lower
energy state is once you break apart
actually let me go down here it's
because I said hey you know this
electron is happier when it's when it's
so let's say this electron that was part
of this phosphorous is happier now it's
in a lower energy state because it's not
being stretched it's not having to spend
time between that guy and that guy
because this molecule this molecule want
to spread apart because they have a
negative charges that's part of the
reason the other reason why and we'll
talk about this in a lot more detail
when we when we learn more about organic
chemistry is that this has more
resonance more resonance structures or
resonance configurations and all that
means is that these electrons these
extra electrons here they can kind of
move about between the different atoms
and that makes it even more stable so if
you imagine that you know this oxygen
right here has an extra extra electron
with it so that extra electron right
there it could come down here it could
come down here and then form a double
bond with the phosphorous and then the
fat and then this electron right here
can then jump back up to that oxygen and
then that could happen on this side and
on that side and I won't go into the
details but that's another reason why it
makes it more stable if you've already
taken organic chemistry you can kind of
appreciate that more but I don't want to
get it you know all into the weeds the
most important thing to remember about
ATP is that when you when you cleave off
a phosphate group it generates energy
that can drive all sorts of biological
functions like growth than movement
muscle movement muscle
contraction electrical impulses in
nerves in the brain so this is the main
kind of battery or currency of energy in
biological systems that's the main thing
that you really just need to remember
about ATP